you get mistaken a lot for silicon
valley's I get command and Jionni
because I names a pretty close Kunal
Nayyar and Kumail Nanjiani and then I
get Aziz Ansari from Isis of none
I get Caliban from Harold & Kumar you
know so it's okay though I mean they're
all handsome talented guys it's nice to
be in that Club I don't mind yeah you
know we text each other we're like on
this like brown guys text group Dex this
time there's a brown guy group tag
exactly we text each other my friend
just got recognized for me and at the US
Customs oh really yeah and then they
didn't make him pay any customs duty cuz
the officer was a fan of the show so
that worked yeah so sometimes when and
it probably works with you guys in
Reverse right yeah absolutely so we'll
text each other and say I just got you
know thanks so much for the restaurant
reservation the maitre d was a huge fan
of Big Bang Theory I'm like welcome
you're welcome and sometimes I'll be
like yeah I'm the guy you know from
Silicon Valley just charged the dinner
to his credit card see you later
[Laughter]
you